[Applaudissements]
lukashenko monde dans un car de police
scandent les milliers de manifestants
réunis place de l'indépendance à minsk
brandissant les couleurs du premier
drapeau de la république populaire
biélorusse de 1918 devenu l'emblème de
l'opposition une dixième journée de
contestation marquée par la décision du
président biélorusse de déployer des
unités armées aux frontières
occidentales du pays
je vous demande de le garder à l'esprit
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas uniquement
des problèmes à l'intérieur mais aussi
ceux qui proviennent de l'extérieur et
nous voyons clairement que ce sont des
activités tout à fait coordonnait mais
il ne s'agit même pas encore du point
culminant la situation évoluera en
conséquence et nous savons déjà
dans quelle direction on des
déclarations qui interviennent alors que
la situation en biélorussie est au coeur
ce mercredi d'un sommet extraordinaire
de l'union européenne une réunion qui
inquiète la russie vladimir poutine
s'est d'ailleurs entretenu par téléphone
d'abord avec angela merkel puis avec
emmanuel macron le président russe met
en garde contre le risque d'une
ingérence étrangère en biélorussie lors
de l'examen de la détérioration de la
situation en biélorussie vladimir
poutine souligné le caractère
inadmissible de toute ingérence dans les
affaires intérieures de ce pays et de
toute pression sur les dirigeants
biélorusses
les deux parties espèrent une résolution
rapide des problèmes actuels emmanuel
macron à lui appelé vladimir poutine à
favoriser l'apaisement et le dialogue
pourtant la semaine dernière l'union
européenne a accentué la pression sur
minsk en ouvrant la voie à de nouvelles
sanctions contre certains responsables
biélorusses la biélorussie qui depuis
2011 est sous le coup d'un embargo
européen sur les ventes d'armes et de
matériel pouvant être utilisé pour la
répression
[Applaudissements]